it is true I believe President Trump is
the most Pro faith president in history
when you look at what he has done for
people of all faiths and mr. president
you know Jewish and Christian believers
alike believe what God said to Abraham
in Genesis 12 that God would bless those
who bless Israel and he would curse
those who curse Israel and I want to
thank you mr. president
for being the kind of president who has
the courage to stand up and be when it
comes to Israel on the right side of
history but most importantly you're on
the right side of God and that's why you
are not going to fail and we're gonna
stand behind you 100%
thank you for sixty five of my 81 years
I have spent at universities all over
the country and all over the world there
is no more important event in those 65
years to turn universities away from
being bastions of hatred and
discrimination than this executive order
being signed today it is a game changer
it will go down in history as one of the
most important events in the 2,000 year
battle against anti-semitism Thank You
mr. president
you did a great great job the people who
helped you do this did a great great job
and you will be remembered by history
for all time for having signed this very
important order thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]